let's just go on issues let's let's do
that okay so when it comes down to
issues what is your position on drugs as
a libertarian what does a libertarian
think about with drugs
that our society would be much better if
we lifted these restrictions and
you know i'd like to point out when's
the last time you heard of a liquor
store owner going up and down the halls
of a high school trying to push bourbon
or when's the last time you heard of a
vodka addict trying to break into a
house in order to support a vodka habit
part of the problem we have with drugs
is the illegality because there's a
profit in there uh if if you're selling
liquor which is legal
now you don't have the profit motive to
try to sell it to kids
it's not worth it for the pennies
dollars you would make to end up in
prison it is however for the humongous
profits that we have
in illegal drugs and studies have shown
that when you make something illegal it
goes up in price by about 20 to 25 times
that's why we have the problems that we
have with so many of that when you make
something illegal the price goes up by
20 to 25 some people in california would
argue that to say in california
they made drugs legal but it was so
expensive like marijuana let's just say
but it was so expensive that drug
dealers were behind closed doors saying
listen you're paying that much for that
here come through me and i'll sell it to
you for this much so still give him an
out for it because
uh uh there was still
you know regulations to it but what
you're saying is let's legalize
marijuana let's legal legalize heroin
crack coke all of that and let's let the
mark get this well let me point out
according to milton friedman we wouldn't
even have crack cocaine if it weren't
for the illegality because economically
it would not make sense to take cocaine
and distill it down to crack cocaine
it's only because there was such a
profit margin that we even have crack
cocaine um and you know i'm willing to
say
uh well first of all i'd like to point
out that so many people were like oh
wait until marijuana is legal we're
gonna see you know
gangs in the street with ak-47s and
we're gonna have and we haven't seen
that what we've seen is basically
peaceful transactions uh if if you want
to do it step by step that's fine but
the longer we wait the longer we're
going to have young kids at risk by
these horrendous drug dealers who are in
it just to make a profit for themselves
one of the bigger issues you're seeing
in california right now though is that
the illicit market or the legal market
for
marijuana is twice as big as the legal
one yes because
they haven't deregulated it because you
they're only allowing a few people to
sell it i mean what would happen if they
did that with alcohol you know there
were only a few people granted the right
to be able to sell alcohol we'd probably
still see bathtub gym and i'd also like
to point out some people say
well but
if everything were legal you know then i
might have a meth house next to me
uh and meth is danger and we all know
about meth houses right
that
it's
toxic
you can die from being in the house
because there's residue and the house
could blow up and it's just a bad place
for people to hang out
well
how many houses you know have you ever
heard of a gin house or a vodka house we
don't have bathtub gin being made
anymore so
if if it were legal
now instead of having a meth house next
to you you're going to have seagram's or
you're going to have you know
phil morris whoever you're going to have
some corporation making those drugs
initially regulated and
safely as opposed to next to you you're
not going to have the drugs you're not
going
it's it's going to look like alcohol
than it does right now so you mentioned
initially regulated but doesn't that
also go against traditional
libertarianism where you don't want the
government to intrude who would be
regulating them oh absolutely
uh we have to work within the system we
have and again there are so many reasons
if we look at the regulation what we see
is we see uh people getting special well
first of all
they get special tax breaks they get
they spend lobbying money and then uh
they get protection so no i i would want
to do away with that but
you can't just overnight have a
libertarian world so just like right now
we're starting with marijuana
we need like i said
uh the the quicker we can legalize
things and the quicker we can get the
drugs out of the hands of the young
school kids so the closest uh uh test
that we have is san francisco right
because in san fran i don't know if
you've been to san francisco i'm sorry
the closest one test like if you look at
what's really taking place right now
with a lot of
drugs that is more lenient san francisco
you got you got oregon you got a couple
other markets but no kraken kraken is a
company if you want to pull up that
article kraken
is a uh company this kraken ceo jesse
powell today issued a statement
regarding rampant crime in san francisco
and the failure of d.a
uh we shut down kraken's global
headquarters on march in san francisco
for numerous employees were attacked
harassed or robbed on their way and from
the office business partners were afraid
to visit
and were victimized crime mental illness
and drug abuse are out of control in the
city which is drastic dramatically
under-reported because it's too
commonplace the police are known to
arrest the same offenders dozens of
times thanks to district attorney
k catch and release program uh which has
resulted in numerous preventable murders
of innocent people san francisco is not
safe and not be safe until we have a d.a
who puts the right of law abiding
citizens above those of the streets
criminals he's so ingloriously protect
so
drugs
you know some may or may i respond to
that yeah but but a parent may a parent
may say
okay so let's just say we legalize it
all right so if we legalize crack heroin
all of that stuff where people can just
get it and you're saying
regulation not regulation
you're saying things like this will
minimize this is going to go away
what i would say is san francisco is the
opposite of a libertarian city it is a
socialist city that san francisco has
got to be one of the worst cities in the
entire country as far as as far as being
libertarian um
they've got uh i mean
yeah it's socialist what can i say and
no they they're not cracking down on
crime i mean i i don't
we can go into the whole crime spree
people walking out the door with eight
hundred fifty dollars worth of stuff how
do
you
know that how do you how do you how do
you address that like if you were in san
francisco right now let's just say your
mayor yeah let's just say you're the
mayor what would you do
well first of all i'd make it illegal to
shoplift i would say
i don't care if you walk out with you
know pack a gum that's shoplifting now i
wouldn't throw somebody in jail for a
pack of gum of course but no it there it
it there's complete lawlessness in san
francisco
and and it to me it is absurd that again
you're a small business owner mom and
pop store
somebody walks out with um
800 and that's okay that's not okay and
once again we get to we've got laws that
are helping the big guys more than the
small guys walgreens who is closed i've
lost track now 14 stores at least
they can shut down 14 stores and then
have 49 other sane states
as well as parts of california that
might be sane and still earn a profit
i have seen on tv so many people who you
know small uh small company it's been
open for generations and now they've got
to close or they've got to move to
another city because they can't afford
to have 800
of stuff stolen or they can't afford you
know that's their only location they
can't say well we'll just you know keep
our virginia uh branch going so once
again we've got laws
that are are helping the big guy not the
little guy and politicians who just
don't care richard branson tom what was
it when richard branson a few years ago
said he thinks we should legalize heroin
and allow people to use heroin i don't
know if you remember that or not there's
been
there's been other people that have been
supportive of this position uh i
remember talking to uh oscar goodman the
mayor of vegas i think his wife is now
the mayor of vegas 21 years of goodman's
the 22 maybe 23 years the goodness have
been mayors of las vegas
and he talked about the same thing he
talked about the fact that if you
want to use heroin you want to use this
you want to use that go at it you had a
similar libertarian belief if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you